this Syrian refugee is shopping at a
German street market when our free Dean
came to Germany about nine months ago
shopping is still something of an
adventure for her Common Council yeah
Margaret debreu a retiree is helping
manar and other refugees with a
transition to a new life she teaches
them German and shows them how to get
around the klaxxi took we go with them
when they have to meet with the
authorities or see a doctor and we do
what we can to help them find their way
deefizzy say what's ashley's manar and
her husband omar fled syria with their
five children now a catholic parish and
bond is looking after that they want to
make a fresh start in Germany the parish
found Omar a part-time job as a gardener
manar says the family just wants to
start living a normal life again ish
mush the UH my Nick Amelia my children
my husband and I just want to live in
peace canada and i want my children to
go to school I want them to learn and
play in peace Leonen it's likely that
the German authorities will grant the
family asylum immigration officials tend
to quickly process asylum claims by
Syrian citizens margot debreu says that
at the end of World War tube Germany had
its own refugee crisis as a millions of
people fled their homes
it was like a mind to keep his feet a
lot of older people in our parish came
from East Prussia and the eastern
territories they were refugees fleeing a
war zone when they arrived here the city
had been destroyed times were tough they
really had to fight for survival and
I've noticed these older people really
give the Syrians of warm welcome in
getting new bezaya of colossal the
latest estimates say that more than a
million refugees are expected to arrive
in Germany this year more and more
politicians are calling for restrictions
on the number of refugees and perhaps
even sealing the country's borders
Margaret says that's unacceptable she
believes Germany should be a refuge for
those in need because odd the strident
50 if people just stick their heads in
the sand and think only of themselves
we're not going to be able to deal with
this situation effectively but if we
take a long-term view and think about
what these people have gone through then
we'll make it the Hadean czar trying to
make it to it'll take time for them to
get used to living in a foreign country
but others have done it and they
probably will too